ادمان رقمي يصيب الشباب وتحذيرات من
استخدامه طويلا حدا اللاوعي مدير هيئه
الصحه العامه في الولايات المتحده
في تقرير طبي كل المعنيين بالصحه النفسيه
للمراهقين مؤكدا ان هناك حاجه ماسه لوضع
قيود تكنولوجيه وحتى عائليه على استخدامها
واستنادا لمركز كيو للابحاث فان نحو 95%
ما بين 13 و17 عاما يشاهدون يوتيوب وسبعه
وستون في المئه يدمنون تيك توك اما
انستجرام فبالنسبه 62% ويليه سناب شات
بواقع
59%
الطبيب اكد وجود صله بين استعمالها وظهور
اعراض الاكتئاب لاسيما على المراهقات
اللاواتي يتعرضن للتنمر اكثر من الشباب
عدا عن ان الفئه العمريه هذه بشكل عام قد
تصادفها محتويات خطيره داعيا الى توصيات
تشبه ما اقرتهم مونتانا اول ولايه امريكيه
تحضر تيك توك لمن لم يتجاوز 18 عاما اما
جوجل فقد وضعت توصيه خمسا لمساعده الابناء
على ان يكونوا مستكشفين امنين لعلم
الانترنت شارك بعنايه وانتبه من التزييف
واحمي اسرارك وانشر الايجابيه وتحدث عما
يريبك اساسيات اذا تعلمها الطفل مبكرا
تحميه من اي اعتلالات نفسيه قد تصيبه من
عدوى وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات